IBM Watson X code assistant for Z the
cloud migration acceleration program and
a beta program for the newest Intel Xeon
processors all on this episode of IBM
Tech now what's up y'all my name is Ian
and I am back to bring you the latest
and greatest news and announcements
about IBM technology
jumping right in I-beam is thrilled to
announce IBM Watson X code assistant for
z a new generative AI assisted product
that will help enable faster translation
of cobalt to Java on IBM Z
designed to help accelerate Cobalt
application modernization Watson X code
assistant for Z will be available in Q4
this year
Watson X code assistant for Z is being
designed to assist businesses in
leveraging generative Ai and automated
tooling to accelerate their Mainframe
application modernization all with the
goal of preserving the performance
security and resiliency capabilities of
IBM Z
the Cobalt data processing language
supports many vital business and
operational processes at organizations
globally at scale using Watson X code
assistant for Z could make it easier for
developers to selectively and
incrementally transform Cobalt Business
Services into well-architected high
quality Java code
the solution is expected to include
IBM's application Discovery and delivery
intelligence inventory and analysis tool
following addi key steps in the journey
include refactoring Business Services in
Cobalt transforming Cobalt code to Java
code with an optimized design and
validating the resulting outcome
including using automated testing
capabilities
to get the full details on this exciting
announcement check out the link in the
description of this video
switching focus a bit let's talk about
Cloud migration the cloud has emerged as
a game changer offering unprecedented
flexibility scalability and cost
Effectiveness however migrating
Enterprise workloads data and
applications can be a daunting
undertaking that's why we're excited to
announce the cloud migration
acceleration program with IBM power
virtual server
with IBM's expertise incentives and
methodologies organizations can
transition their on-premises power
environments to IBM power virtual server
easier than ever before
benefits of the program include a
streamlined process that includes
prescriptive guidance comprehensive
business and Technical planning and
strategic support from IBM onboarding
and migration specialists
clients also receive guidance from
technology Specialists from IBM expert
Labs who have access to proven migration
patterns code tools and Deployable
architectures specifically designed for
IBM cloud
the cloud migration acceleration program
guides clients through a structured
process to migrate workloads to the
cloud keeping things timely and in order
to learn more hit the link below
finally we're pleased to announce that
the beta program for 4th gen Intel Xeon
scalable processors on IBM Cloud virtual
servers from VPC is officially live
customers can Now preview one of the
industry's newest microarchitectures
inside their own virtual private Cloud
at no cost and gain access to a host of
core compute enhancements including more
memory per vcpu than ever available on
IBM cloud
it's important to consider your workload
performance requirements before entering
this program your options are two preset
pneuma align profile families
balance profiles are for a mix of
performance and scalability and they are
ideal for more common workloads memory
profiles are best for memory intensive
workloads such as large caching and
database applications or in-memory
Analytics
overall we think this beta program is a
smart no cost entry point into premium
Hardware especially for those looking to
develop and test heavy application
performance and investigate performance
uplifts when porting to new platforms
hit the link below to learn more
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now